hello everyone and welcome back to the
Grand final of the Champions Chester AI
cup it's not the Grand Final it's
actually the Grand Final reset because
mag Maxim won the Grand Final now in the
final Magnus defeated Maxim but then
Maxim bounced back and then uh in the
Grand Final he defeated Magnus he won
the first game and the next three games
ended in a draw so uh Maxim won that and
now they are in the Grand Final reset
where Maxim won the first game so now
Magnus absolutely needs to win with the
black pieces in order uh to force
further tie breaks now as much as you
guys enjoyed the me playing some games
in the previous video it's time to
return to some uh top level chest so
let's check it out Maxim has the white
pieces and he opens with E4 and Magnus
again sticks with the Sicilian Defense
we have Pawn to C5 Knight F3 we have
Pawn to E6 and pawn to D4 we have
captures captures and now Pawn to A6 the
con variation of the cilian uh and while
it uh does
um it does tend to create some tricky
positions you haven't played Knight to
F6 so D4 Pawn is not hanging and Maxim
is by no means obligated to play Knight
to C3 so he opts for the marozi U bind
structure uh now the D5 scare is nicely
covered uh we have Knight to F6 Knight
to C3 and now Queen to C7 putting more
pressure on this C4 Pawn but you know
preparing the the standard stuff we have
A3 B6 and Bishop to D E3 uh Bishop to B7
putting pressure on D4 Pawn but for the
moment it's nicely defended we have
castles and now Bishop to D7 is the move
that's most played here but Magnus goes
Bishop to D6 and now there are a couple
of games where H3 was played but we have
F4 by Maxim and it is now already as of
move 10 that we have a completely new
game so okay he opened up this diagonal
Magnus pins the Knight with Bishop to C5
and Bishop to E3 now the Knight cannot
move for the moment as Bishop captures
on E3 would come with check so Knight to
C6 piling up on the D4 Knight and Knight
back to C2 Maxim opts for some trades
here we have Pawn to D6 and queen to D2
We have Castles by Magnus and Rook a to
E1 so all of Maxim's pieces have now
been developed uh Magnus goes for Knight
to G4 puts pressure on the bishop here
and Maxim trades on C5 so captures
captures and now Pawn to E5 this opens
up Maxim's diagonal for his life Square
Bishop but it also opens up magnus's
diagonal for his light Square Bishop we
have Rook 8 to d8 nicely aligning The
Rook with the queen and queen to E2
putting pressure on the Knight and
getting out of the way so Knight goes
back to H6 the Knight will be REM
maneuvered over to F5 hopefully and Rook
to D1 now so the queen can move as the
bishop was hanging would be hanging on
D3 with Knight to D4 by Magnus attacking
the queen so Maxim captures it C
captures and now Knight to E4 and here
we uh reach a very interesting moment
where you know that something is about
to happen on that King's side and the
Magnus needs to decide how to play this
now you could of course Play Bishop
captures on e4 but it's such a weird
engine move that no one plays and after
Queen captures you just play G6 and okay
uh you take you've taken care of the
light squares you don't have to worry
about the Queen Bishop battery the
Knight can safely be put to F5 it's
actually more than playable position for
black but Magnus goes Knight to F5 he
wants to keep his light s Bishop as it's
also a tremendous piece uh Rook to F3 by
Maxim and only now Magnus plays Bishop
captures an E4 the reason why Magnus
captured now H is that he wants to play
Knight to E3 and this is a beautiful
Square for the Knight the problem is you
get destroyed if you play this and by
destroyed I mean white has Knight to F6
with check and now if you don't capture
then of course the H7 Pawn will be under
a lot of pressure from the knight from
the rook and from the bishop here uh so
you would have to capture and then comes
a second piece sacrifice Bishop captures
an H7 with check this is all very
standard and of course both Maxim and
Magnus um see this in the blink of an ey
and it doesn't matter if you capture the
bishop or not um this is even more
resilient but you know just to show you
if you capture Rook H3 check King to G8
and now Queen to H5 uh Checkmate cannot
be defended and if you don't capture it
if you go King to h8 then uh just Rook
to G3 and there is no defense the queen
is coming to H5 with some uh you know
the bishop can just move and it will be
a nice Checkmate so you cannot go Knight
E3 and that's why Magnus first
eliminates the Knight here so okay
Bishop captures we have Bishop captures
uh and now Knight to E3 and here You'
probably expect Maxim to just move the
Rook with something like Rook E1 or Rook
to D2 or Rook to C1 H but no Maxim
actually played Bishop captures on H7
and this is where the fun really starts
uh it's not a great move but Magnus is
um sort of expected to play exclusively
perfect Moves In order to survive this
and uh well eventually win the game as
this is not a good move uh so King
captures an H7 and now Rook to H3 it's
not a good move or a great move but it's
a great practical move so Rook to H3
check and now you cannot go to G6
otherwise Queen to H5 is Checkmate so
Magnus play King to G8 and now comes
Queen to H5 and now there is only one
winning move for Magnus and uh it's not
an easy one to spot Maybe you guys or if
you've seen the game of course you know
what I'm talking about but if you
haven't feel free to pause the video and
try to find the only winning move for
Magnus while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on finding
the move that usually loses all games
but here it it actually wins one and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Pawn to F6 believe it or not
this is the move that wins and the move
that Magnus played Pawn to F5 does not
win the game but we're going to get to
that as this is really really exciting
Queen to H7 check what happens if this
is played in this hypothetical line well
King F7 and now after e captures an F6
looks uh dangerous but you have Rook to
G8 this is the point and this is how you
save the game and now if Rook to G3 of
course white will try everything to win
that black queen on C7 you will simply
play King captures on F6 even this is
possible and now if Rook to G6 check
King to F6 and queen to H5 threatening
some nasty discoveries uh you just say
have at it I'm just going to uh help
myself to the rook and D1 there are no
useful discoveries here and once you uh
look at the position once again there
really aren't so you're going to
continue attacking Pawn to F5 uh but it
doesn't matter look at this Pawn to
D3 it's absolutely disgusting how how
strong this position for black is you
could throw one Discovery but after King
f8 no continuation here you can even
play f six but then comes Queen to C5
check forces a queen trade and that's
pretty much it your your attack has
evaporated so uh F6 winning for black
Magnus plays Pawn to F5 and the problem
is it's not that it's not winning is
that it's possible for maxim to now
force a TI Force three-fold repetition
uh and of course that means that he will
win the match so Queen to H7 check was
played King to F7 and now Maxim plays it
I'm sure you guys um already know what
I'm talking about uh you
know uh Rook to H6 and now when Magnus
saw this he was very much disgusted with
himself you could see it in the camera
uh the problem is there are a couple of
moves of course you could consider one
is Knight capture Sun D1 it's the most
obvious one so we're going to C so we're
going to see what happens if Knight
captures on D1 uh Maxim's idea is Queen
to G6 check and after King to G8 now you
will of course just go for the
repetition if you go King to E7 then
Queen captures an e six is Checkmate so
you go back and now Maxim just repeats
and he's very happy as he draws the game
and he wins the match another move of
course we're not going to do that
another move we might consider is Rook
to G8 that was winning in the other line
where F6 was played uh but here it uh
it's not winning due to Rook to F6 with
check King to E7 and now Queen to G6 and
now what do you play here uh Queen to F7
will be Checkmate so how can you uh stop
this well you could play Rook d to f8
that's one way to do it but then comes
Rook captures on E6 with check and okay
you start running King to d8 but now
comes Rook captur on D4 with check King
has to move and now you could capture on
B6 you could win the black queen doesn't
really matter everything is winning here
so what you would have to do after Queen
to G6 is actually take the Rook uh but
now it's uh Queen to H7 check the pawn
still prevents the king from going to D6
King to E8 and now you will take the
black queen and okay Knight captures on
D1 but now e captures on F6 and you
cannot stop Checkmate so uh very sad if
Rook to D7 you just play Queen to C8
check now if the king moves you can
simply gobble up the rook and if the
Rook blocks just Queen captures an E6
with check King to f8 and now Queen to
E7 will be Checkmate so Magnus quickly
saw through this and he tried one last
idea Queen captures on C4 uh hoping that
Maxim does not played the only winning
move but when Maxim saw this he I'm sure
he felt great relief as he played it
pretty MCH instantly and that of course
is Rook to F6 with check uh sad but true
for Magnus King to E8 and now Queen
captures on G7 and he was in this
position on move 29 that Magnus Carlson
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so he resigns the
game with it the match and Maxim wins
the Champions Chester AI cup beating
Magnus not once but twice two matches in
a row so he won he defeated him in the
Grand Final and also in the Grand Final
reset which is uh I don't know uh if
anyone ever did that like okay Magnus uh
was known to lose a match here and there
but you know beating him in a match and
then beating him in a in a fresh match
uh I don't think that ever happened
probably did but uh you know uh such an
event does not come to mind now here you
resign okay Magnus could have played a
little bit longer but it just uh there's
no point of course um the queen cannot
move Rook captures and E6 would be
Checkmate if you don't move the Rook
Rook captures and f8 will be Checkmate
so what can you do you have to capture
The Rook but now comes e captures on F6
and again you can't stop Checkmate how
are you stopping it now now you can move
the queen because the E6 Pawn is not
hanging but now F7 with check and now if
King E7 of course this will just be
Checkmate so you have to go to D7 and
now f8 Queen opens up a discovery from
the queen here King to C8 and now you
will play Queen F to F7 and uh black is
not in time to grab material you are a
threatening Checkmate again so Queen to
C6 can stop this but now Queen to A7 and
Black's position is just dead there's
nothing you can do uh no no move you can
make uh whatever you do queen captures
on A6 is the threat again you don't have
time to to capture The Rook you can play
something like B5 uh but then after Rook
to E1 uh no move again you you cannot
move the Knight to C4 Rook captures on
E6 would attack the queen and you can
never uh move the queen otherwise Queen
A8 will be Checkmate H you could play
something like Knight to G4 but then you
sacrifice the queen and after the queen
captures now of course the C file has
opened up rook to C1 with check and now
if you move the king of course Queen to
C7 is Checkmate and if you block with
the queen it's again Checkmate but only
in a few more moves Queen C7 King A8 and
Rook captures on A6 will be Checkmate so
really really a wild game where it all
comes down to this point uh you know
Maxim uh such a such a troll troll you
know sacrificing the bishop like this
but uh you know it doesn't matter if it
works or it doesn't it's it has a
practical chance of working out even
against Magnus Carlson uh so there you
have it um F5 F5 is insufficient F5
doesn't lose the game F5 is a draw but a
draw in this situation in the match is a
win for maxim and of course he was very
happy to receive that whereas F6 and the
position is still winning so uh I mean
sometimes uh these are the critical
moments uh so uh of course Magnus knows
this but in your own games if you face
such a move like Bishop captures on H7
you should just recollect yourself uh
come down and you know you know that
this doesn't work you you've had similar
positions so many times uh uh but you
know it it often comes down to this uh
when it's a sacrifice on the king side
it often comes down to this uh uh push
of the F Pawn now whether it's an F6 or
F5 uh you know be careful when it
happens in your own games uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by Maxim winning two
matches U against Magnus in a row
absolutely incredible I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to Kevin
toplas and I would like to thank
George de Gregorio Jonathan Johnson
Robert araton and sash p p puru for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and if you
haven't seen my previous video I played
some very nice chess uh do check it out
uh see you
soon